hey guys it's rob i hope you're all
doing well i've been gone for a bit i
know but i'm back now i got some new
equipment i cut my own hair and i'm
ready to make some videos
now while some people said that the
ninja star boomerang was fake it doesn't
work or it just isn't fun to play with
my new kitten suki is a professional
addict
as you can see and she absolutely loves
to play with it in all seriousness
though i do want everyone to be able to
fold it and also to enjoy it and have it
returned to them
so today i'm going to introduce the
ultralight ninja star boomerang
it uses a lot less paper to 1 8 strips
of printer paper
so it's a little bit easier lighter and
simpler to fold
and interlock not only that but with one
sheet of printer paper you can make four
ultra light ninja star boomerangs even
though it flies in a little bit of a
smaller circle it comes back super fast
and it's easy to catch
if you saw my origami convention video
you'll see that with practice i got just
about everyone to fold and catch their
boomerangs
if you use the right paper and you
practice throwing and folding it
you'll be a pro in no time and it will
come back to you i'll explain the paper
you need and also some troubleshooting
tips towards the end so without further
ado let's get folding the ultralight
ninja star boomerang
i'm using bright letter sized paper with
a gsm
of 89 which tells you how thick the
paper is but pretty much any eight and a
half by 11 letter sized or
a4 proportion paper will work fine just
note the weight on the package or cover
i found a gsm or thickness of the paper
between 75 to 100 works the best
anything below or above that may be too
flimsy or heavy and not fly properly
we'll have to get the paper's width
into eighths like these strips which
means we'll have to cut the paper
in half three separate times if you'd
like two different colors then you'll
have to do it with two sheets hold the
paper so that the longer edges are
horizontal and fold it in half
lengthwise you can use scissors
or if you're good at tearing you can do
that i like to first press in the middle
and slowly line up the paper to the
right and left before i make the final
crease
we can finally fold the paper in half
one last time and then tear it when
you've done that three times your paper
will look like this
for the second piece you can keep the
other half you just tore away or use a
different color
[Music]
let's take the left side and fold it
across to the right side
hold it so that the edges are aligned
and just crease it on the left side by
just running your fingernail against
it you can open it up so that it looks
like a little mountain
and set it down on the table the right
edge
is going to go down into this vertical
line
so just line it up and then give it a
crease
on the right side here now we can take
the left side
and fold it up onto that vertical line
also making a crease on the outside here
then we could flip it over just give it
a quick press to flatten it out and
you'll notice there's a horizontal
crease here
lift up the right side so that it is
even on the bottom
with the left side as you could see here
now i'm just going to take my
fingers here my two pointers and pinch
it in the middle and set it down
on the table and i'm going to lift the
bottom edge
to the top but i'm going to leave a
little bit of space
as you'll see from here to there it's
about three to four millimeters
then you can just pinch it in the middle
with your two fingers like that
and just press down gently in the middle
making a little pinch in the paper like
this
now that we've marked the distance in
the middle we have to make sure that the
edge is the same distance and parallel
to the top one all throughout
so i'm just going to bring it up a
little closer here because i want it to
be three to four millimeters then i can
crease it all throughout the right
and do the same with the left side
making sure that this edge here on the
bottom
aligns with the top one equally then you
can just run your fingernail against the
bottom edge
just to ensure that it's really sharp
and easy to fold being careful not to
pull it apart
i'm going to lift up the middle portion
and the bottom edges that we just folded
in
unfold the right side and you'll see
that we now have two new creases in the
paper here
you see there's one here and the other
here on the top one we can actually just
take that edge and fold it down because
it's in the right direction but this one
is a mountain fold and we need to flip
it so just simply set it down on the
table and put your nail directly in it
and kind of press on it
you can also lift up the paper and kind
of look at the crease
so you can press on the opposite ends
and just flatten everything out
you'll notice the bottom right edge was
lifted up and the top left edge was
lifted down
so that they're now overhanging as you
could see here
there should be a gap of about three to
four millimeters like i said previously
flip it over set it down and we can move
on now you've got past the hard part so
we can just
unfold these edges that we just folded
in and we're going to airplane fold both
of the corners here into the midline
the right triangle that you see should
be bigger than the left one
once you've completed that then you can
do the same on the other side
and we're going to fold the edges back
down so that we have the overlaps and
flatten everything out
now we can just lift both sides at the
little corner that we have near the
diamond in the middle
and we're ready to make another one
[Music]
now that we have two pieces fold them up
slightly at the corner near the center
diamond where i've drawn the line
and place the one on the right
perpendicular over the left one
we can then fold the top arm of the
boomerang down and go in a clockwise
direction
proceed to fold the second and then the
third
you'll notice because of the overlap it
will not fit perfectly and this is okay
just proceed to slightly untucked the
first one and bend the last one so that
you can tuck it
underneath the first now that it's
tucked in we need to make sure that the
middle is tight
so pull on the opposite arms gently and
make sure that they're folded
all the way up to that corner press down
firmly in the middle and flatten
everything out
we can now fold that overlap or airfoil
down so it's laying
on top the other edge as flat as
possible so fold it down
along the edge all the way to the center
just like that
if it rips slightly at the center it's
usually okay
but just try and be gentle and it should
look like this
fold them all down along the other edge
and crease them
sharply once we finished folding all
four of the airfoils or flaps down
we can flip it over and we're going to
flatten it down with our fingernail
and sharpen the ends this is necessary
to help it
spin and fly once you've finished all
this you've done
the ultralight ninja star boomerang and
you're ready to do a test flight
[Music]
to throw it first inspect it and make
sure it's neat flat and that there are
no major bends
also hold it so the four interlock
squares are facing the left
grab it between your right pointer and
middle finger on the end of an arm
and the rest of it should be facing your
body curl your wrist and we're going to
throw it slightly
out slanting to the left like this
okay so it went to the left
let's try that again
okay so the boomerang works well just
make sure you're flicking your wrist at
the correct speed
and not holding on to the boomerang for
too long or it can go to the ground
or spin off to the left it needs to spin
sideways at an angle like a frisbee so
you need to get that curved wrist action
going
if it goes to the left more than once
try adjust it by bending the arms away
from the square side just like this
then try throwing it once again and it
should fly better
[Music]
sookie
i hope you guys enjoyed the video for
the ultralight ninja star boomerang if
you did be sure to give it a thumbs up
down below and click that notification
and subscribe button if you haven't
already
[Music]
i'm trying to come out with more videos
um i know it takes me a while and that's
because i've been trying
i've been trying to make more original
videos meaning i've been trying to
design my own things and that takes time
uh but it shouldn't take that long i i'd
also like to expand and try different
things
i was thinking another rubik's cube
video i was thinking other
cool paper stuff maybe quick things like
other paper footballs and stuff like
that
i also did a live zoom session where i
taught a couple different things
happy birthday frankie i think that
there might be other people
who might want to perhaps do that and
if i set up like a patreon or something
where we can communicate and maybe do
live sessions i bought some new
equipment uh i'm working on my
my editing technique to make it easier
for me
because when i do teach it sometimes i i
talk
during the teaching and that makes it 10
times harder because if i mess up
i wind up having to start all over again
so it takes so long so what i'm going to
do
is i'm going to concentrate more on the
filming aspect and then just just double
over it later and explain it really well
that way
see if you like it so if you did like
the different angles
in the video uh let me know give me a
comment down below and let me know if
you have any ideas for something you'd
like to see in the future
all right guys i gotta take a nap and
rest my back so i'll see you soon
i hope you guys enjoyed the video